[Musik]
ja leute 5 punkte was der kerl hat sich
persönlich sage ich habe eine menge ganz
eine glanzleistung je zehn punkte hätte
ich mir gegeben hätte was die dort
willkommen bei einem neuen video jahr
wollte ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's
gut bin ich noch nicht ganz mit der
belichtung zufrieden mit meinen haaren
auch nicht aber egal die outfits hole
das zeug wieder raus
ich hoffe euch jetzt gut mir schon es
ist nur extrem warm hier und wir haben
heute wieder phänomenale unterstützung
und zwar die wunderschöne bezaubernde
schon mal her nicht zu brav blumenwiesen
mädchen ja heute wären heute mache dabei
und vielleicht kennt ihr die videos von
mir wo ich letztens irgendwann mal
outfits vorgestellt habe das ganze fand
ich zwar immer schon cool aber ein
bisschen langweilen deswegen haben uns
heute überlegt in kooperation mit junk
iata habe ich wieder einige coole
klamotten bekommen suchen wir uns jeder
mal klamotten raus die der andere noch
gar nicht weiß um dann halt so ein
outfit zusammen zu stellen also es geht
heute einfach stumpf darum jeder macht
sein eigenes outfit und der andere muss
das bewerten
ach so okay ich hab das noch ganz
gedeckt so um das ganze ein bisschen
interessant zu machen habe ich hier
gerade ein blog gekauft von jedem preise
und der andere ist immer die jury und
muss dann halt nimmt zahlt von 110 auf
diesen blog schreiben und dann schauen
wir mal wer am ende besser abschneidet
und ich würde sagen ich fange einfach
mal an weil meine klamotten sind der
absolute oberhammer leute also ich will
gar nicht lange lagern und vorgaben mit
auto nummer eins präsentiert von mir
alle links zu den ganzen outfits sind
wir mal und in der video beschreibung
von irgendwas cool findet kopf durch
gerne oder halt auch nicht und haben wir
noch irgendwas wichtiges oder also
outfit nummer eins nationen also was mir
richtig gut gefällt ist auf jeden fall
die hose und die schule gefallen mir
richtig gut das oberteil auch hat mir
auch richtig gut das ist halt nur nicht
genügen
alles ist sehr sehr gut hat so ein
bisschen so ein basketballspiel auf
jeden fall
und du hast was mir auch sehr gut
gefällt mal passende socken an sind ja
von trank er richtig schön einfach liebe
aber danke man echt nett von dir gut
[Musik]
ja so recht traut
also ich muss erstmal sagen auf jeden
fall nicht von schlechten eltern
ich finde dieser sein wird schlug
zwischen dem kummer oberteil der
schwarzen hose und dem weißen schuhen
super auch den pullover von der rihanna
kollektion richtig mit bauchfrei kann
man im sommer auf jeden fall gewagt gut
tragen genau
insgesamt gibt es von mir für dieses
outfit ich sag mal so gut gemeinte acht
punkte noch dazu wenn die nicht kommen
wir zum nächsten outfit
[Musik]
da hast du natürlich einen richtigen
[Applaus]
nähe ist nicht gut
also ich finde im pulli ganz cool finde
ich sogar sehr
aber der sieht genauso aus wie der gelbe
den wir weiter und zwar geholt haben
zusammen allerdings hat der haltigen
streif meine seite was ich cool finde
die lose ja aber was auf hindi muss sich
nicht so geil pulli ist gut
kombi ist auf jeden fall gewahrt
ohne schuhe ja auch nur langsam
schneller autos ach so ja aber damit
finde ich dich jetzt nicht so attraktiv
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
gut gemeinte werde ich das leben mit ihr
auch die aktion erkannt leute 5 punkte
was ich dir sage ich habe mir eine
glanzleistung je zehn punkte hätte ich
mir gegeben
kommen sie kommen sie
[Musik]
also fangen wir mal oben an
die haare kann man nix machen
akzeptieren wir einfach mal so wie es
ist den pulli finde ich genial würdest
du jetzt du den pulli anziehen würde ich
in der 10 punkte geben
die hose passt gut schönes weißes schön
schlicht findet sich sehr mit dem ping
von polit auch dass man so ein bisschen
im knöchel sieht finde ich auch super
schuhe absolut scheiße
deswegen gibt es von mir gut gemeinte
siebeneinhalb punkte
[Musik]
also das ist mein eigenes favorite
outfit wenn euch das genauso gut gefiel
mir vor allem die akte hier darum herum
oder der pulli so mein lieber freund so
heinrich auf jeden fall richtig cool ich
find's gut dass du diese größen die
graue hose mit der jacke ist ja schön
flauschig wie ich sehr und ich finde die
kombination wirst du deinen füßen echt
gut
ich hätte jetzt nicht ins blaue zu dem
ganzen bin ich nämlich nicht so mann zu
finden das nie ich bin schwarz zeit
angepasst die die du als allererstes
anhalt es hätten richtig gut dazu
gepasst mit der weißen sohle oder die
weißen hätten dazu gepasst
um nochmal diesen thread schlug dem auch
irgendwie genannt hast auch zu überlegen
also eigentlich hätte ich lieber auch
neun punkte gegeben aber die schule habe
es halt draußen also ich finde das echt
sehr modisch beim passend übereinstimmt
so letztes auch für vor maria es kommt
womit ich nicht gerechnet hat okay dann
mal
[Musik]
kranke fuß erst einmal dagegen drücken
wird da einmal hiergegen aber gut immer
die filme noch so von unten sind gerade
irgendwie wieder pollen unterwegs also
irgendwie muss ich den kassen wiesen ich
muss sagen dass pepsi oberteil sticht
mir sehr ins auge ist natürlich äußerst
sommerlich gehalten
kombiniert mit dem rock und dem gürtel
also das ist ab sofort teil in davos ist
gefällt mir ich habe auch passen dazu
sage ich mal normales sommeroutfit zwar
ein bisschen aufwendiger wegen dem pepsi
logo deswegen gibt es von mir hier
lasst euch nicht lügen einfach mal
wieder genial gemeinte acht punkte als
geschnitten
bist du damit zufrieden ja das waren
einige outfits von uns ihr könnt ja
gerne mal in die kommentare schreiben
welches euch am besten gefallen hat wie
schon am anfang gesagt alle klamotten
sind in der video bestimmung verlinkte
merkt jetzt gewann ich oder weil ich
habe dir automatisch schlechtere punkte
geben damit ich gewinne ich hätte es
gemerkt immer mit deinem lied gemeinden
acht punkten lassen
wir sehen uns morgen ja ich möchte noch
was sagen haut rein